et
ensemble au livre des records il s'agit
de la plus grosse compagnie aérienne du
monde occidental united airlines qui
passent la plus grosse commande d'avions
jamais enregistré 110 boeing 737 300 et
cette commande va permettre à une
société aéronautique française la snecma
d'obtenir un contrat aussi important que
celui de rita passé chez thomson
pourquoi parce que les boeing 737 300
sont équipés de moteurs d'origine franco
américaine les cfm56 dans l'immédiat ce
contrat va rapporter 4 milliards de
francs à la société nationaliser qui les
fabriquent la snecma l'entretien des
réacteurs de ville devrait lui rapporter
4 autres milliards le cfm56 représente
décidément un fameux moteur pour
l'exportation française à lui tout seul
en 84 il a rapporté plus de devises à la
france que les avions d'airbus industrie